hello everyone and thank you for tuning
into my presentation external protein
synthesis in new development in
degeneration
my name is Uli shanks I'm an assistant
professor of pathology and cell biology
working the top Institute for research
on Alzheimer's disease and see aging
brain here at Columbia University in New
York if you think about how our
understanding of a cell is being formed
and if you check any standard textbook
about cell biology it will probably come
across a picture just like this a cell
is depicted as a small roundish entity
without really much spatial
differentiation however in reality sites
are told look totally different and you
will have a hard time of finding such a
low answer even in relatively simple
organisms such as yeast cells or fallow
flowers you will find differentiation in
daughter and mother cells on the leading
edge or trailing edge whereas in all
innocence you have apical to basal
specification the spatial
on morphological differentiation of
cells is nowhere more pronounced and in
new ones where you have a vast
difference between dendrites and axons
all of this then leads to the question
how gene expression is regulated in the
spatial dimension of course the standard
answer to this is that mRNAs our
translated into proteins somewhere in
the cell body and the localization
signal leads to the transport of the
proteins into the periphery of the cell
however more recently and this should be
the focus of this talk it has come to
our knowledge that mRNAs most of the
time the cerebrum utrs of mRNAs contains
his acting elements that derive
transport of Emma
as into the public fully offset and only
within the pollution of the sides in a
single dependent manner most of the
times the mRNA is being translated in a
just-in-time just in place fashion to
give rise of differences in protein
expression of course sir all of these
those processes are part of the post
transcriptional regulation of gene
expression that is as in my view as
important as transcriptional regulation
of gene expression once you have an mRNA
being trans quiet listen the nucleus
it's being processed processing might be
for example splicing after kala sesang
of the mRNA is being exported into the
nucleus into the cytoplasm and a
different set
partially overlapping set of transacting
factors of proteins bind to the mRNA
they together regulate for example
instability but also the transport and
eventually the translation of the mRNA
all of these individual steps together
lead to a spatial temporal control of
gene expression
most of the since acting elements as I
said before that regulate processing
transport stability and translation of
mRNA at least in mammalian cells are
encoded in the sweet one untranslated
regions of the cells of the mRNA we have
the sward evolutions many examples are
for mRNA localization even in the most
simple in the simplest organism such as
ecoli or yeast as I mentioned mRNAs are
being transported and signaled
apparently translated for example h1
mRNA in budding yeast that is being
transported into the budding
daughter sir more and very extensive
mRNA localization is known from
Drosophila and from Singapore suicide
also in fish and mammalian cells M&A
localization is very pronounced fairly
recently work has founded for example
Donnelly podía of fibroblasts in which
in a specific subset of mRNAs that are
anchored to the tips of the mr of
microtubules so focus of the talk today
is mrna localization in new ones mainly
developing neurons but shortly also our
adult news and just for completeness
sake also other sides in the nervous
system such as oligodendrocytes contain
extensive MRA look localization as I had
said under in the very beginning new
ones are extremely polarized we all know
this we have identity collaboration that
can take many shapes and forms here are
some examples given and every neuron
contains exactly one axon the axon is
separated from the summative into two
compartments with the axon hillock this
acts as a diffusion barrier meaning that
there is no it's very little passive
transport or diffusion of components
from the small identity component into
the axons the meaning that mRNA that are
found in axons are there because of an
active transport mechanism importantly
to notice also that axonal and dendritic
mRNA composition is completely different
and the external transcriptomes
are distinct and separate in both of
their complexity and composition from
the somatodendritic transcriptome one of
the most important or striking features
for serologist looking at an axon is the
last difference in size a classical cell
body
of a new one is something like 20 to 50
microns in diameter whereas an exome can
spend can easily beat up to 1 meter or
Swee feet in dimension and to bring this
a little bit more in in the macroscopic
scale if we would understand that a new
on cell body is as the same diamond is a
baseball baseball having a diameter of
seventy four millimeter an exon on this
scale what would spend roughly 5000 feet
I think this brings sort of to mind the
vast difference in scale between exons
and cell bodies and also leads to a
couple of questions because normally we
do not understand new cells to be
microscopically large such as 1 meter
for example one question that a virus
from the vast distance of an axon is how
is material biome how are proteins being
transported into the periphery we know
very well how fast proteins can be
transported is this mainly done through
experiments using radioactive amino
acids given specifically to the cell
body and then testing after certain time
intervals where the radioactive label
coatings show up and so we know by now
that there are different speeds of
ex-owner transport for example until
grey transport is relatively quick
there's a weight of 200 to 400
millimeters a day and I have given here
on the side the the time it would hardly
try to travel a 1 meter exxon versus
transport speed so for an Telegu a
transport it's not so bad it's 2.5 days
however a lot of these transport this
intelliwhite transported of the fast
nature is specific for membrane proteins
and lipids whereas a lot of other
proteins especially proteins that make
up the cytoskeleton
are transported
slower and here transport can take
several months so this is a problem that
we hardly ever think about because we
don't think about it coatings are very
stable for this time and I'm not saying
that this injuries talk I have no answer
to to all of the sponsor device from the
slow transport speed but suffice to say
that relatively early it has been
recognized that slow transport within an
axon and the last distances that the
single neuron can spend will will force
us to maybe adapt our understanding
about basic cell biology in fact already
very early on in 1899 Llewellyn Barker
hypothesized in his local boards or
another system that it might be that the
Exile would actually not receive all of
its nutrient material from the ganglion
cell meaning the cell body but what
other s would seem up here a much more
likely receive part of its material
swimmin on trophimus metabolism so in
slightly more modern terms he already in
1899 posts a question whether excellence
are able to synthesize proteins and if I
speak with undergraduate students always
laypeople they don't seem to have much
of a polo business concept however the
more progress in science my counterparts
as and more arguments I have against the
existence of local translation and
excellence mainly because it it seems to
go against several Dogma that we hold
dear and so this is really a very old
debate or already in 1897 Karla Schaffer
did his staining for mrs. substance
meaning for an a which structures he
identified for each one process that
turned out to be the excellence that is
devoid of any new sustained meaning
being devoid of a however already in
1943 and a was detected in embryonic
axons and this is an important point
while cava had looked at adult neurons
in this paper embryonic excellence were
being studied and clearly embryonic
axons contain an A according to the data
from 1943 however the in 1955 again a
very influential article found that they
are absolutely no ribonucleoproteins
detectable in zxo pleasant but again the
authors of the study looked at a direct
axons in 1960 in a quite elegant
experiment dogs were being subjected to
poisonous substance that irreversibly
inhibits acetylcholinesterase and she
also checked in nerve segments where
does a secure cholinesterase activity
emerges and what they found is that
independent of layer along the length of
an axon you look as it will call an
ester base activity just appears exactly
at exactly the same time so this can't
be all this seems to be contradictory to
the idea that the protein is produced in
the cell body and then until quietly
transported along the axons so
conclusions that tonic and Colonel posed
at the time is that acetylcholine
esterase is being produced locally in
1970 Virginia Tennyson's and provided
direct evidence for the existence of
poly ribosomes in again developing axons
not mature exons by e/m and the field
got a lot of more dynamic balance
eternal so essentially when Gary Bozell
identified the first mRNA to be
localized to both
and axons mainly be directin you can see
here strong fishing in a individual new
light being the axon and finally in 2001
christine whole school from cambridge
published a very influential in iran
article to which I will refer in a
little bit in which she presented for
the first time direct evidence at Luca
translation in excellence is required
for excellent development a couple of
years later beat and found the first
specific mRNA or a that is required for
specific own behavior course cone
collapse in response to semaphore ensue
a however just to be very open about the
debate is not yet settled for example in
2009 poorly to annul published an
article in journal of neuroscience in
which he finds that protein synthesis in
digital excellence it's not required for
both ground responses and so as a whole
as a scientific discussion about this
question in those on but are saying that
by now I think the overhanging evidence
argues that local translation listen
excellence is important for development
of exons and possibly also for
maintenance and degeneration and
certainly for regeneration so coming
back to the original findings from
Christine
she studied exon pass finding and calls
from behavior and response to new owner
guidance cues during the development the
excellence of have to call really
complicated
paths with the developing nervous system
and they are being held by attractive
and repulsive guarding skills even
swords is guidance cues further into
secreted long-range cues such as a net
oneself or lines that can be both at
and repulsive or contacts meaning sir
surface guidance cues such as F winds
cat hearings and so on in Christine
holds apology you with retina
acts on X plus retinal X plants from
Xenopus I and in this X plants it is
possible to cut the cell bodies so that
only the axons have shown here stay
behind and such a cut axon will stay
alive and we continue to grow and to
react to exercise our guidance cues for
several hours so now if you for example
apply net when in a 45 degree angle to
one of this cut axons and keep in mind
there is no cell body around anymore the
excellent will contain react by turning
away from the source of network if you
do this with quite a lot of excellence
you find that the average turning angle
is negative however if Christine hold
applied an ISO maizena a protein
translation inhibitor excellence didn't
care about the net when gradient anymore
at all
and you have no bias for a turning angle
at all anymore the same was to not only
ways with uh nice amazing but also this
cycloheximide
another protein translation inhibitor
and because the cell bodies has been cut
away whatever is being inhibited here in
terms of translation has to be
necessarily local translation based on
this experiment and many other
experiments she developed the following
signaling pathway variables semaphore
and scree a and net will lead to the
activation of translation local protein
synthesis and protein synthesis then
effects in some way decide the skeleton
leading to negative to the polishing or
goes con colics however at the time it
was not known which proteins are being
synthesized beause it responds to sama
fallen or to net clean and mediated
local Costco and changes in course combi
area I hope you can still see me I got a
little black out here okay so I'm going
on at this time then we started
investigating which mRNAs might be
locally translated and based on the
ghost cone collapse and protection
phenotype we speculated that the small
gtps might be involved and we focused on
for a and indeed doing using in situ
hybridisation meaning a standing the
earth specific for mrna we could
identify the both ETA actin but also for
a we're heavily localized two exons as a
get forty squeeze account are staining
whereas walk or wag mRNAs were totally
absent the same wizard can be also seen
here in rt-pcr made on x ona
or whole cell are libraries so know that
we knew that for a mrna was a lot we
wanted to help way of directly cooling
that whole a a man is locally translated
in a semaphore ensuite a dependent
manner for this we designed or the used
by our reporter system originally
developed by erin human school in which
we have a membrane-bound
destabilized egfp so new aesthetic means
that the review egfp cannot diffuse
because it is bound to the membrane so
destabilization
gives us a half-life of just a couple of
minutes something like half an hour and
we all were expressed this mRNA in the
context of the sweep on utrz
untranslated region of hue the idea
behind this is that now destabilized
membrane-bound egfp is being translated
in exactly the same manner in which
endogenous or a mrna is being translated
and indeed if you look at this face
contrast images here you see the egfp
signal you see that they are a couple of
egfp positive sports this means this is
where this in the last half an hour this
construct has been translated if you
stimulate number 16 for 60 minutes with
semaphore and sway in this excellent you
see that many many more and tighter of
these hot spots appear we can quantify
this by doing this dot blots in control
condition citizens a blue color the
intensity and the number of the hotspots
doesn't really change how L always in
our phones we a you get a lot of new hot
spots of MOA expression and most of them
are buffs for T to the dividing line
meanings intensity goes up
so same affordance we a induces
translation of for a but it's lower a
translation required for the effect of
semaphore in suis a for this we can use
compartmentalize Chamberlin's
in this case accompany chamber where we
place cell body C and the central
compartment and the excellence go to
both sides and the side compartments we
establish that it is possible to use as
Ayane against mRNA specifically in the
side compartments CSI will lead to a
knockdown of the mRNA only in excellence
without being grito greatly transported
to the cell bodies in this a way we can
establish a
condition in which Newlands contain no
glow ASI on a anymore nouveau am on a
anymore in their excellence and if we do
this you see that semaphore and sweet a
absolutely fails to induce oscon
collapse whereas the control is iron and
obviously does not lead to suppression
of semaphore and phenotype so with this
experiment we can show that local am an
is required for seven points we hate but
the question is whether for a mRNA alone
is sufficient for semaphore in sweet a
induced
OSCON collapse for this we have to
establish a condition in which all other
mRNAs that are present in axons are not
being translated with the exception of a
we used here molecular biology twig and
by overexpressing or a in the context of
an iOS internal ribosome and besides
containing one spot if he just over
expresses constructs it has no effect on
the on the way of course con collapse in
response to semaphore in suis a it is
still around seventy to eighty percent
if we completely inhibit local
translation local translation Bassanio
myosin
you see that course con colors is
completely abolished however if you use
another translation inhibitor rapamycin
localizing does not inhibit course
controllers in response to same as VA
and the difference is that while any
surmising inhibits all kind of
translation rapamycin inhibits only kept
dependent translation and all construct
here for though a does not contain a cap
but an iOS as an initiation sites there
for optimizing is unable to inhibit the
translation of low a of this construct
so we create indeed a situation in which
only of all a is being locally produced
no other Aman
yields protein and yet we find semi
dependent calls can collapse meaning
that global translation of a alone is
sufficient for semi induced or strong
colors so this all together leads them
to the as a smaller for the first
identified mr as it has to be locally
translated in response to our semi
signaling obviously whole egg production
alone is not sufficient because as a
small GDP as it has to be activated and
then it leads to log activation and goes
can collapse and example traction
however furiously different exercise or
Gardens queues do essentially the same
trick by causing the local translation
of different mRNAs for example slip two
also leads to horse complex and this is
again work by Christine whole school she
uses the same approach here with severed
axons you see here control goes corn
that will collapse if you apply slow to
and the collapse is not inhibited by
inhibiting transcription but it is
inhibited by unasur mice and
cycloheximide protein synthesis
inhibitors so again slip tool requires
local translation and it leads to local
protein synthesis in this case it is not
for a that is - that is being locally
translated but cofilin mrna coughlin
mrna is heavily localized to exons and
bolus cones and up an application of
slit tool you see that supporting
Levites go heavily up but not and
obviously unasur myosin and
cycloheximide leads even though the
mRNAs around will prevent the increase
of hopefully encoding so this leads to
the plaza puzzling question why would
different transcription factor
different guidance cues meet with a
local translation of different proteins
that have similar effects in a follow-up
study we asked the question which are
the proteins or the protein that is
locally translated that would support
exon cores and lead to close
collaboration as opposed to a retraction
and we focused here on the cdc42 + 3 / 6
polarity complex it's mainly because it
was a master regulator of cellular
polarity and directly affect societal
skeleton and in many instances such as
the arrogant zygote or epithelial cells
but also nuanced it was found that the
complex specifically localized to
certain regions of the cell in the case
of new and specifically to the tip of an
axon and so we asked whether any of the
EMR as making of the proteins making up
this complex might be localized to exons
and indeed we found that persuade mRNA
the mRNA coding for the on central part
of this complex is indeed heavily
localized to excellence by heavily
localized you have to take my word for
it and believe your computer screen that
there actually is a single but you can
also look here at the quantification low
a and plus we mRNA are roughly equally
expressed and confirmed by rt-pcr we
then wanted to establish whether or not
the repair complex is indeed required
for exon goals for this week prepared an
ex-vivo essay where we take embryonic
who had spinal cord and do an open book
operation so we cut along the doors a
part of the spinal cord segment and flip
the the spinal cord open
and then electrical AIGFP together with
ion a into the doors 1/2 of this open
book preparation and then after 48 hours
we can see the cell bodies labeled and
the excellence going towards the midline
crossing and turning so this is how it
looks in reality you see here the cell
wall is a commercial cell bodies the
exons go towards the midline and John if
he overexpress a console is ayane again
so board is labeled exons layered cycle
and quran if he knocked on paths we or
plastics exons fail to be too close
towards the midline or to reach the
midline they still glow but they go much
much slower you can see here couple of
these axles so this let us to speculate
and indeed as a park complex is required
for attractive goes towards the midline
and this good means that for example
possibly might be locally translated we
use the compartmentalized culturing
system to which I will come back in a
little bit to directly pull sepkoski is
locally translated so our ideas at ngf
leads to local translation among them
pass us we might locally translated so
we just applied ng F locally and
measured call speed of over an one hour
period quantified here ng F leads to an
increase in those feet however if we
locally apply pass we si on a all other
mRNAs are still intact exons completely
fair Juliet was increased all speeds in
to ng F meanings that's an activity of
mechanism by which ng F induces X angles
involves local translation of pathway so
this then let was a model for attractive
or a whole four of local translation
attractive cause that naturally binds to
its receptor leads to local translation
of pathways that sin leads to the
nucleation of the park complex that you
can see here and you get in effect exon
out course and cytoskeletal dynamics so
this way are now a couple of examples
that came together over the years at all
follow essentially the same systems that
you have excellent guidance cues up here
that lead to local translation of some
mRNAs that then have effects that are
either attractive all the parts of what
is far far worse and or less understood
is how precisely the regulation happens
meaning how does binding of ligand lead
to local translation of very specific
mRNAs one idea is based on a paper from
2010 by John Flanagan's who who found
that ribosomes or Arizona subunit such
as the 40s and 60s subunit entrant
ribosomal initiation factors can bind
directly to the cytosolic domains of the
ligand of guidance cue receptors such as
DCC leading to the idea that up in
binding of in this case net when the
ribosomes are being released locally
leading to the local translation of
mRNAs that are present in present in arm
keys
for other systems we know a little bit
about for example their trust relation
also zip code binding clothing is
important for the activation of
beta-actin translation we know that
other mRNAs are regulated through
different proteins such as CDP in
general it seems to be that location
that binding of a accessory signal leads
to a local signal transduction cascade
that oftentimes involves kinase that
then lead to very specific local
translation of mRNAs the mRNAs on the
other hand are being transported in very
specific when you it's meaning complexes
between transacting factors and mRNAs in
a keynesian dependent manner into the
exons and why they're being transported
there being subtle translationally
silenced and create they wait for the
signal
under peripherally to be locally
translated so we know this and it allows
us now to summarize a little bit what we
have learned over the last 15 years or
so most of the work as I said has been
done in embryonic excellence during
development where we by now have very
good understanding that guidance huge
queues lead to local translation of
cytoskeletal proteins but also signaling
molecules such as creb 1 they tend to
gather lead to axon pathfinding but also
axon branching in the case of beta-actin
for example possibly synapse formation
so this is all on the embryonic side and
as I said doing the as a part of the
talk where I talked about the long
debate whether or not
excellent translation is happening at
all the situation indirect nuance seems
to be fairly different this is mainly of
evidenced by the fact that there in the
diet exons
certainly far fewer em on a abundance
and we have polls detecting any local
translation at all so the debate right
now is going on whether and died
excellence at all are able to point to
produce proteins locally however
recently again Christine hoard school
has shown that lamin b2 is locally
translated in exons and is required for
activity of mitochondrial qualities if
you don't have the local translation of
lamin b2 exon maintenance is greatly
impaired so this is the first
interesting hint at a role of local
translation in more mature exons clearly
once you enjoy an excellent and this is
mainly work by Mike finds a liver and
gently twist and others you will find
where its reactivation or activation of
local translation a very specific and
distinct set of mRNAs is being looked
recruited into the exons and you have
local translation of both nuclear
factors but also cytoskeletal proteins
together this local translation in
response to nerve injury is required for
recourse of the attempts of wiegel's of
exons and the transcript terms that have
been identified of injured exons contain
many cytoskeleton and injury response
proteins meaning that there is hope that
made interference with local translation
after nerve injury might be a way of
helping axons to regenerate what we
don't know in any office
instances is why is local translation
here preferred as opposed to transport
from of the proteins from the cell body
philosoph
we have no fear no understanding was a
new degeneration meaning very old axons
might be activated
local translation as well and this is
really the these are the two questions
that we follow in my own group yet
Columbia quite a bit so what do I mean
that we don't know much about the
rationale I started with the slow
transport of mRNAs into the periphery
and one could argue that this is
justification enough however if one
looks a little bit more closely you will
find that only 4.8% answers give or take
obviously of all transcripts are found
in Costco and this means that it's a
minority of the whole XOR of the
wholesale your transcriptome is
localized and even for mRNAs that are
localized for example in the case of
acting beta-actin and Xu Berlin less
than 1% of the actin and fueling and
excellence is actually locally
synthesized 99% come from the cell body
so it is very difficult to understand
the transport is efficient enough for
99% but not 400% so transport efficiency
probably really isn't the reason why
local translation exists further we have
absolutely no correlation between
porting function size or characteristic
and the question whether or not they are
locally translated so it remains an open
question why in some instances but in
many other instances not local
translation is being used and I came to
believe that there simply isn't anything
like a general explanation for local
protein synthesis and that we have to
look more precisely at each individual
instance to find a solution while local
translation might be more advantageous
yet and in the following couple of
slides I want to give you an example for
how we think about this so our
hypothesis was that local translation
might be uniquely suited to integrate
two seemingly separate pathways that
always have to happen at the same time
in the same place and our example says
here was again X on our course I talked
before that attractive guidance few such
as net win on commercial excellence ing
effandi AG excellence neat local
translation of paths we data needs to
the park complex for attractive
excellent elongation however if you
think about what must happen within an
excellent all let attacks on out course
it is clearly not only the side of
skeleton but you also have to have a lot
of membrane expansion and so we were
wondering how is remembering expansion
tightly both spatially and temporally
synchronized with cytoskeletal dynamics
so the question is its local translation
maybe a connecting link between this two
seemingly parallel pathways in this
instance in this if this hypothesis is
wide we would have a linear pathway that
leads to activation of local translation
of pivotal proteins in both of the
following pathways and because they are
being mostly translated at the same time
in the same place all the membrane
expansions as cytoskeletal dynamics
pathway would kick in necessarily always
in a synchronized fashion so to look at
this V of course first have to know how
the membrane is being expanded during
attractive our course and surprisingly
for us membrane is added more or less
exclusively versus the goalscorer so
membrane
plasma membrane kickers are they
radicals ppb's
are being produced from the golgi in the
cell body and then transported along the
exons into the ghost cone and here in
the EMU see this ppb's as this lauren
structures that then i being tailored to
the membrane and fused with a member in
to enlarge the membrane this became
visualizes by using a fluorescent
membrane marker body pfl c5 ceramide and
the interesting
for the biophysical property of body pfl
c5 ceramide is at very very high
concentrations such as you can achieve
only in the Golgi it will form
intracellular X Imus at fluorescence wet
whereas normally it is green this leads
to the effect that the ppb's are all the
plasma membrane precursor vesicles are
layer to it whereas the surface is
labeled queen now if we induce membrane
expansion we receive fusion of ppb's
poozer
accessory to the plasma membrane by
disappearance of this label PPVs and
direction and indeed this is what we use
and test in our microfluidic chambers
that allow us to see new and
specifically to one side of these
mikrotik dividers and I predict dividers
Michael grooves that are 10 microns or
20 microns wide and Sui microns high and
in this case it might be 200 or 500
microns long due to hydrostatic
differences there is no exchange between
the ex-owner and the cell body side so
that we can apply ng F or any kind of
whatever we want
essentially selectively to axons without
interfering with the cell bodies so we
do this here in the system again we have
the cell bodies on one side of the
dividers and retweet the axons only on
the other side of the divider we load
our cell bodies with our membrane dye
and you see here is a control situation
a lot of bullhead staining up in
stimulation the red staining totally
disappears you to the fuel due to the
situation of those member and precursor
vesicles with a membrane if we locally
apply a nice or myosin or cycloheximide
or EMA teens we are structurally
unrelated coding translation inhibitors
you see that we get
a complete inhibition of the lack of
membrane expansion so membrane expansion
requires local translation the question
is of course what is being locally
translating so we looked into the cell
biology of PPV turbulent with a membrane
followed by fusion and so tethering
closest is being mediated by an
polluting complex called The Exorcist
containing a different exercise proteins
and a small GDPs called TC 10 and
interesting enough both a component of
the exercise cord ii 6 and TC 10 itself
had been previously described by various
groups to be part of external
transcriptions so we asked whether
either or both of these proteins might
be locally synthesized and mediate local
translation we actually couldn't
reproduce the sex 6xo shisui
localization our resource at TC 10
assembly localized post to excellence
posed by a t PCR and by fish and the
standard experiment again if we we we
looked for his local TC 10 fluoresce in
influence levels and we saw that up an
energy of stimulation it goes up quite a
bit
however if we inhibit translation by
locally applying and summarizing or
cycloheximide there is no significant
increase and if you use TC tennis ion a
there also is no increase in response to
ng F so TC 10 is locally synthesized but
it is required for ng F induced X or an
elongation
so here again we do an X on our course
si over one hour SP for four parts we
and T C 10 si on a completely it's down
here completely abolished course in
response to ng F and the same is true
for all body PSA if you use TC tennis I
RNA locally we do not see fusion of the
ppb's with a membrane so this together
leads to
the following signal transduction
Cascades and attractive guidance to you
such as ngf lead to an activation of PSV
kinase because if we use pi3 kinase
inhibitor such as Wortman and we
interfere lessly this production of both
TC 10 and pass we the same is true for
FDI 227 a web inhibitor or dialect web
knock down all for our myosin so we get
this linear cascade that attractive
guidance cues due to activation of PSV
kinase act CSC to web mTOR important
synthesis of those paths we and TC
Tenon's it is exactly what we had
hypothesized originally so we know for
the example of this two mRNAs we have a
better understanding why local
translation might be preferred and we
believe in deeds of local translation
integrates most membrane expansion in
cytoskeletal dynamics leading to
external elongation in the last slide of
the start I really would like to very
quickly talk about a potential for
excellent translation and neo
degeneration and I refer to it already
this is Christine poets work in which he
shows and extrinsic use lead to the
local translation of lamin b2 and
surprisingly lamin b2 that is not up to
now had been mainly understood to be a
coating of the nucleus of the nuclear
lamina a nuclear envelope is locally
required for mitochondrial fitness if
local translation of lamin b2 is
inhibited
she finds mitochondrial dysfunction
followed by excellent degeneration and
this is extremely tantalizing now
because auxin APPA the-- is part of many
many new degenerative disorders
and it leads us to speculate and to
actively investigate whether maybe local
excellent translation is being impacted
in new degenerative disorders and levels
changes in axon transcriptome or local
proteome a part of pathogenic pathways
leading to new degeneration so in some
early over the last two decades or so we
have learned that developing excellence
certainly and for mature excellence it
is still an open question contain mRNAs
and closing translation machinery and a
distinct subset of mRNAs is recruited
into exons in a situation dependent
manner for example I mentioned injured
or regenerating excellence that
contained a different subset of mRNAs
and developing exons and these m on is a
locally translated most often in a
single dependent manner and effect for
short periods of times the extremely
localized transcriptome and based on
transcriptome analysis so far a picture
emerges in which many of the localized
mRNAs code for proteins as functional in
protein synthesis itself like ribosomal
subunits and proteins that regulate
cytoskeleton and intracellular signaling
however the deeper the sequence and we
are using RNA seek for example this view
might change and we find many many more
cellular functions that are represented
in the external transcript also so
coming back to the original question why
is their local translation happening at
all one example one possible explanation
is just in time just in place delivery
certainly single amplification we find a
lot of singing molecules in the case of
synapse is a very nice idea is a tagging
of substantive domain so you can
deliver proteins very very specifically
to micro domains there is a possibility
that locally translated proteins have
distinct properties due to for example
selective concentration modification and
I saying that we provide evidence that
local translation can lead to the
integration of seemingly unconnected
parallel pathways that always have to
have an entire synchrony let me finish
by acknowledging the people in my group
we do this work nearly equations Amina
Bali Ola Chandler Joel Jose and hooray
our collaborators at Cornell and finally
the funding agencies who make all of
this possible and finally if you're
interested in seeing me here so atlas
I'm now going to click on the questions
that came in during my talk and I have
here a question it seems likely that the
question is oops I forgot okay it seems
the most examples you bring up of local
excellent translation involves
translation of actin cytoskeleton
machinery as a neuronal Cortines like
acetylcholine receptors also expressed
regulated this way okay so the answer
for this is that many examples of the
best that it mr as it are locally
translated so far are indeed
cytoskeletal proteins or regulators or
societal skeleton however we are now
understanding that many other put a lot
of other proteins and other protein
classes are regulated in the same way in
terms of other two choline receptors
it's still not quite understood
whether receptors it all can be locally
translated we find em on s4 receptors
however we do not see Golgi the Golgi
apparatus is clearly not present in axon
so we have sent to ask the question how
is the secretory pathway functioning in
the periphery there are some indications
that there are gorgey like structures
and go G like functionality in the
periphery in axons however the final
functional proof has not yet been made
and so in the end we don't know whether
for example as a true colon receptor is
regulated school local translation -
other-- question here when of the HPA
axis has any influence on external
protein synthesis and to my knowledge
this question has not yet been addressed
experimentally at all also a lot of the
research on exploring translation is
still on the level of individual
research meaning finally cultures mainly
and we are just now developing the tools
to go into living animals to ask
questions such as it would apply more on
a whole organ organism level there is
another question that asked there are a
few evidence there's few evidence that
suggests that Milan Dibley might be
taking applies in you on a soma can I
saw some light on whether it's being
whether it's being metabolized or
whether this ok so the question here
relates to some fairly over the last
couple of years there are a couple of
indications that there might be
horizontal transfer of my
here from clear cells or from Schwann
cells for example choose the axon and of
course this is a very nice idea that
maybe an a can be transferred directly
and being taken up however it hasn't
really been proven to have any
physiological relevance as of yet
another question is in gloss currency a
lot of ribosomal protein mRNAs and
translational proteins such as EF or e
or a year 4G why do I saying that goes
cones might need to synthesize ribosomes
locally so this is a great question in
any transcriptome that you do on axons
you will find ribosomal subunits either
proteins or an ace to be
over-represented and what these things
that is something like a feed-forward
mechanism you have originally you start
out with very few localized ribosomes
but then for example up north quash or
injury or stimulation in any other way
you get first an amplification of the
translational protein synthesis
machinery that is localized and then you
get a lot of other coat proteins are
produced from locally produced forever
somes so the presence of existence of
ribosomal protein mRNAs within course
cones are saying is an indication that
they gives the possibility for rapid
amplification of the protein synthesis
ability I'm flicking school more
questions so at the moment I do not see
any more questions and the ones that I
have answered if anyone in the audience
has more questions please type some now
otherwise
the time on the air is anyway coming to
an end and I thank you all for your
interest and for participating in my
presentation today and wish you all
still a nice and interesting bio
conference thank you for your interest